it goes from like
could you not make me dim my light to
could you also like raise my game if i'm
here
can you go there because it would be
nice also to aspire
you know i wouldn't mind someone who
like made me
in excited and intimidated even i don't
know yeah
that's nice like not intimidated in a
bad way but like
wow like you've really got it going on i
don't know
that's what i'm looking for
what like what's your type i if you look
at the people i've dated i think they're
definitely
physically all over the map okay um i
definitely need a sense of humor that is
i cannot i i just that is so key i
really love someone who's funny that
yeah that is an aphrodisiac to me i do
like a funny guy sometimes i do guys who
are like oh i can one-up you and be
funnier than you and i'm like i get paid
you're like probably
funnier
you know
do you like what kind of type of man are
you looking for okay he's got to be
breathing he um
he has to have a job you know uh his own
money
um
he has to be nice to me
which is like wow nicole
you need to like aspire to something
bigger but i'm like no no just like a
nice hello and a smile would be nice you
know
so sad how hard that is to fight i know
all joking aside right nice where's the
nice man
where
where
i did a lot of guys who listened to
podcasts
well hopefully they're listening to
yours and listening to what your wish
list is and getting ready to fulfill it
drew that's so nice thank you from your
lips to god's ears all right
i can be nice
if anybody messes with you however you
should send them down the wipeout course
okay please talk to me about this show i
love this show so much first of all john
cena oh what a dream i mean he's so nice
i love him he's so nice um i asked him
if i could do the wipeout course and
they were like kind of leaning towards
letting me do it but then right before
we started shooting the first season i
fell down my stairs because i was too
excited to leave my home
and
i dislocated my ankle so they were like
no
no absolutely not you can't do this now
but yeah it's so hard
there's like also this thing that for me
feels like such a life metaphor you're
just walking around this thing and this
big giant bubble puncher comes out of
nowhere and just
sucker punches you 10 feet
and i'm like that's life it is life yeah
okay we have to cut to a quick
commercial break i want to come back and
talk grand cru which everybody is like
saying this is the new friend
and it's so exciting i watch the whole
documentary of the making of we'll be
right back
[Music]